18 عاما بعد اقراره يصدق الكنيست
الاسرائيلي على الغاء بنود في قانون
الانفصال احادي الجانب عن قطاع غزه واربع
مستوطنات في شمال الضفه الغربيه المحتله
كان يحضر على المستوطنين دخولها واخليت
عام 2005 هي اجراءات جديده تنسجم وسياسه
حكومه نتنياهو الجديده المدعومه من قوى
اقصى اليمين الداعمه للاستيطان وتهويد
الضفه الغربيه والقدس فالاتفاق الائتلافي
بين اللكود والصهيوني الدينيه نص على
التزام الحكومه الجديده بفرض السياده
الاسرائيليه على الضفه الغربيه والاعتراف
بجميع البؤر الاستيطانيه غير القانونيه
تطالب حركه الصهيوني الدينيه بضم المنطقه
من مساحه الضفه الغربيه الى اسرائيل وبناء
على هذا الاتفاق انشئت وزاره خاصه داخل
وزاره الدفاع يشغلها وزير الماليه
سموتريتش فاضافه الى توجيهه للموازنات
سيشرف على مشاريع الاستيطان
ترخيص المستوطنات الجديده
ويمكن للوزاره مراقبه البناء الفلسطيني في
الضفه الغربيه وبالتالي اصدار الاوامر
بهدم المنازل الفلسطينيه في المنطقه جيم
تحديدا بحجه انها بنيت دون تصاريح نتنياهو
ايضا التزم امام وزير الامن القومي اتمار
بتمرير قانون يشرع فرض حكم الاعدام على
الفلسطينيين الذين ينفذون عمليات ضد جنود
او مستوطنين وليس اخرا اجراءات التنكيل
التي اقرها في السجون وادت بالاسرى
الفلسطينيين الى العصيان رفضا لاجراءاته
بينها مضاعفه عمليات العزل الانفرادي
وحرمان الاسرى من العلاج وبعض العمليات
الجراحيه وزياده عمليات الاقتحام والتفتيش
الكنيست مرر ايضا قانونا مثيرا للجدل منح
بنكفير صلاحيه مطلقه على قوه الشرطه وحرس
الحدود العامله في الضفه والقدس والمناطق
التي يقطنها فلسطيني الداخل هذا سيعني منح
المستوطنين اليهود حريه اكبر الاقتحام
المسجد والتقسيم الزمني والمكاني له
والتوسع في قمع الفلسطينيين كانت اتفق مع
الليكود على تاجير مناقشه قانون اخر مرتبط
بمنح حصانه لقوه الامن بعد ان حذرت
المستشاره القضائيه للحكومه من تعريض
افراد اجهزه الامن للملاحقه القضائيه في
الخارج وفيما يعد تشريعا لاستهداف
الفلسطينيين اكد وزير الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي انه يعتزم توسيع معايير ترخيص
الاسلحه لدى المستوطنين في الاراضي
المحتله وتسهيل الحصول عليها فيما يبدو
تشريعا للقتل بحجه الدفاع عن النفس
[موسيقى]